Britain and the EU would be happier if
they got divorced that's the motion for
this intelligence squared debate from
London
[Music]
[Applause]
well hello I'm Nik gowing and welcome to
Cadogan Hall here in London nearly 1,000
people here gathering to debate one of
the most contentious issues in politics
Britain's relationship with the European
Union well Prime Minister David Cameron
promised that if the Conservative Party
wins the next election the UK will hold
an in/out referendum in 2017 so the
motion tonight Britain and the EU would
be happier if they got divorced and we
have a stellar panel for you arguing for
the motion Daniel Hannan Conservative
member of the European Parliament author
of a doomed marriage Britain and Europe
and Nigel Farage also an MEP leader of
the UK Independence Party you you Kip
and against the motion
Katinka bearish german-born deputy
director of the center for european
reform and independent london-based
think-tank and Leon Brittan British
politician former vice-president of the
European Commission currently vice
chairman of UBS investment bank well
shortly you'll hear from all four
panelists - for the motion - against the
debate will then be thrown open to you
in the audience here and you were all
cold as you came in to this hole for
this debate we'll give you that result
after we've heard from our four speakers
you will vote again at the end to see
how opinion has changed how it shifted
how many more have abstained how many
more have moved in one direction or
another so there's much to speak for
tonight let's now move on with the
panelists to make their opening
statements in this intelligence squared
debate on Britain and the EU would be
happier if they got divorced speaking
for the motion Daniel Hannan journalist
author and politician he is currently a
conservative MEP fluent in Spanish and
French he is known for expressing his
trenchant Euroskeptic views in the
European Parliament Daniel Hannan the
floor is yours
thank you ladies and gentlemen a
judgement for most countries EU
membership was a product of pessimism a
confident optimistic country country
like Norway or Switzerland feels no need
to trade in its present liberties
certainly in our case we joined at a
moment of great despair the early in
mid-1970s were perhaps our lowest time
as a modern country those of you who can
remember will recall what it was like
with the three-day week with the prices
and incomes policies we with a sick man
of Europe we had double-digit inflation
constant strikes trade union problems
and we looked across the channel and it
seems to us that Western Europe had
discovered something that we were
missing between 1945 and 1973 the year
that we joined Western Europe had
spectacularly outperformed the United
Kingdom had outgrown us for reasons
which we can now see we looked across
and we thought we need to hitch our
wagon to that locomotive my friends our
timing could not have been worse we
thought we were joining a growing and
prosperous market in fact we were
confining ourselves in a cramped and
dwindling customs union far from
hitching our wagon to a powerful
economic locomotive we shackled
ourselves to a course and we did so at
the moment that the developing markets
not least those of the Commonwealth from
which we had crazily stood aside were
beginning to take off according to the
IMF over the next five years the
eurozone will barely grow at all but the
Commonwealth will grow at 7.2 percent
per year that is the central fact of our
existence here's the extraordinary thing
we are paying for the privilege
and paying very substantial sums how can
we sustain morally or economically a
situation where not only we but all 27
member countries are making difficult
spending cuts at home and every penny we
save is being sent to Brussels for what
benefit I'm sure we'll hear about peace
in Europe so what else have we got out
of it
I won't even touch on the constitutional
and democratic objections the fact that
our laws are now made not just by people
that you didn't vote for but by people
that nobody voted for by 27 unelected
European commissioners people who
generally have to have lost an election
before they're appointed to the
Commission a uniquely anti-democratic
system so let me instead ask you this is
it possible to conceive of a situation
where we could have the advantage of
trade in Europe a free movement of goods
and services while at the same time
being able to lock in to those global
markets well the short answer is to look
at the countries already doing it
outstandingly Norway and Switzerland the
two after members of the two large after
members both of them are fully covered
by the so-called Four Freedoms of the
single market that is thus a free
movement of goods of services of people
and of capital but they are fully
sovereign democracies and critically
critically they are able to sign free
trade deals with countries outside
Europe we can't do that I don't know if
you've all seen the current Bond movie
Skyfall it's a rather touching moment
where Judi Dench playing em quotes
Tennyson's Ulysses and she applies the
words to our present condition as a
country though we are not now that
strength which in old days moved earth
and heaven that which we are we are we
are the seventh largest economy in the
world we are the fourth military power
on the planet we're one of five
permanent seat holders on the UN
Security Council one of the group of
eight industrialized nations we are
implausible as it sounds the eighth
largest manufacturing economy in the
world
our languages are most widely spoken by
the human species we have unparalleled
links with the United States the
Commonwealth the rest of the
english-speaking world how much bigger
do we have to be before we are able to
thrive running our own affairs in our
own interests tho much is taken much
abides and tho we are not now that
strength which in old days moved earth
and heaven that which we are we are
Daniel Hannan thank you speaking for the
motion that Britain and the EU would be
happier if they got divorced now the
first voice against motion Katinka
bearish welcome deputy director of the
Centre for European reform based in
London born in Germany
and she works to improve relations
between member states of the European
Union could think of bearish the floor
is yours
hello good evening I
I am from Europe how many of you have
been to one of the other 26 you
countries raise your hands wonderful
isn't it wonderful and diverse but hold
on a minute katenka you're going to say
what has this got to do with emotion
what has Europe got to do with the
European Union it is the job of the EU
to make sure that people business and
money can flow around this wonderfully
diverse area of 27 countries freely it
is not the job of the European Union to
make these countries the same if the
European Union that I know is diverse
and free why do the Euro pessimists tell
us that it is burdensome purakh Rasik
and bullying as an economist I tell you
let's look at the underlying principle
we need some common rules in Europe to
make the single market work the single
market allows British business to sell
freely into an area of half a billion
consumers half a billion wealthy
consumers before we had the single
market a company taking a truckload of
stuff from London to Rome would have
signed 88 different pieces of paper
today one before the single market there
were in Europe 100 thousand different
sets of technical regulations today one
common rule book so the whole scary
question by
simply down to this what purely British
rules be less burdensome for business or
more burdensome I have no idea what I do
know is that if Britain makes its own
rules that are different from those on
the continent it loses access to the
safest and biggest single market in the
world we've become cynical about the
achievements of European integration
peace blah blah freedom y'all but my
father was a refugee
he wasn't even allowed to live in his
own country I want my daughter
I want your children to have the freedom
to look for opportunities on the entire
continent I do not want them to be stuck
behind high national walls erected by
the Europe SMS and talking about
opportunities and freedom the European
Union owes its two biggest recent
achievements to this country to Great
Britain these are the single market and
the enlargement to take in the post
communist nations you fought for this
you won and Europe is better for it and
let me assure you that also today you're
not alone in wanting to change the
European Union one more time to the
better angle America wants a small EU
budget just as much as David Cameron
habeas dingy to Britain has allies it
can work with them to change things the
Great Britain that I have come to know
and love over the last 20 years as the
conviction and the courage to do this it
is not a defeatist little islands that
squeezes its eyes shut in hopes that the
world will go away ladies and gentlemen
friends we the other Europeans want you
to stay the French want you to stay
because they share your global outlook
and your courage to act abroad the poles
want you to stay because they also
cherish close ties with the American
and we Germans want you to stay because
we need a liberally minded ally when it
comes to open markets and trade so
there's only one thing for us to do here
tonight and in the future that is to
reject that motion and let's stay in
this together
Katinka bearish thank you very much
indeed now let's shift back to the
motion itself for the motion we have
Nigel Farage leader of the United
Kingdom Independence Party you Kip
member of the European Parliament he
famously survived a plane crash on the
day of the general election walking away
from the wreckage relatively unscathed
Nigel Farage the floor is yours
thank you
well good evening everybody coming from
a very middle-class family of people
that were involved in business my
parents quite naturally in the
referendum in 1975 voted for us to stay
part of a common market because it
seemed like rather a good idea doesn't
it but the trouble is that the small
print of this was never ever explained
now I first got involved in this when
Britain joined the Exchange Rate
Mechanism
it seemed to me to be utterly stupid
that we should wish to pegged sterling
against the deutsche mark given that we
had completely different economies I
didn't believe it would work but I have
to tell you that my view since I've been
there has changed I now don't just want
the United Kingdom to leave the European
Union I want Europe to leave the
European Union because they've hijacked
it that flag that anthem Herman Van
Rompuy I mean who has ever asked for
this who has ever voted for this but
just look how they behaved when the
European Constitution was drawn up and
the French had a referendum on it they
said no the Dutch had a referendum on it
and they said no and everybody knew that
a majority of Member States being given
a chance would have said no to a full
political union what did they do they
rebranded it as the Lisbon Treaty and if
that wasn't bad enough they removed the
prime minister of Greece mr. Papandreou
when he dared suggest they should have a
referendum they even removed the Prime
Minister of Italy mr. Berlusconi he may
have been past his sell-by date but to
think that they've stooped to those
levels well they actually remove
democratically elected prime ministers
it says to me that the EU cannot be
reformed
it isn't undemocratic it's
anti-democratic and what about the rule
of law well it's supposed to be a treaty
bound organisation with a clear set of
rules but as we saw with the bailouts
there was no provision in the treaties
to bail out country after country but it
didn't matter because now there are no
rules
and even in my diary's predictions I
would never ever have thought that we
would have seen the events that took
place in Cyprus where literally these
gangsters have stolen money from
people's bank accounts to help prop up a
failing European Union they have sunk to
an all-time low
they now pose a serious threat not just
to democracy not just to the European
economy but I genuinely now believe that
we will see a rise in violence and real
political extremism because Europe has
now been split by this moronic idea of a
single currency split from north to
south and far from being a Europe in
which we love each other it's becoming a
Europe in which frankly everybody now
hates the Germans now I have to say
speaking to this title to this motion
that I do want us to get divorced from
the European Union but I want it to be
an amicable divorce and I say that
because I'm not anti European at all
indeed I'm married to a girl from
Hamburg yes so no one needs to tell me
about the dangers of living in a German
dominated household
no I want us to have a good trading
relationship with the European Union but
not to be part of a political customs
union and I'm very struck that there's a
group of countries out there with two
billion people in them where common law
predominates where English predominates
countries out there that are our friends
our own kith and kin around the world
and it is a dreadful thing that we
turned our backs on the Commonwealth all
those years ago and we should re engage
with those new thriving english-speaking
markets across the world we've got to
have a global future for this country
not just a little backyard European
future in short I want us to regain our
self-confidence come on we're British
we should govern ourselves we should
insist that the only people who should
govern Britain should be us through the
ballot box and if we don't like our
governments we can turf them out and get
somebody else to do it and the good news
is this line of argument isn't just
winning in this country it's winning
across the rest of Europe to thank
Nigel Farage thank you very much indeed
so you've heard the two leading voices
for the motion let's hear the second
voice against the motion Leon Brittan
Lord Britain as he is now British Home
Secretary and mrs. Thatcher a prime
minister not known for her pro-eu
sympathies also a former vice-president
of the European Commission and as long
Fort Europe's corner against the more
Euroskeptic wing of the Conservative
Party Lord Brett the floor is yours
ladies and gentlemen I am prepared to
concede one thing and one thing only
to the proponents of this motion I have
no doubt that if we were divorced from
the European Union there would be a
momentary feeling of liberation because
exemption from any system of rules and
regulations you first have a feeling of
freedom but the question is how long
would that last because the basis for
feeling happy is the assumption which I
believe to be a wholly false one that
leaving the European Union we would
continue to have all the benefits and we
wouldn't have any of the disadvantages
and that frankly is arrant nonsense
is it really conceivable that we would
be allowed to continue to trade freely
to have the benefits of freedom of
movement of goods services of people and
we would just be able to carry on the
same as no longer members of the
European Union why on earth should our
partners agree to that happening why
should they let us have our cake and eat
it and this is not just a theory and
this is an obvious statement of
political reality whereas some of the
statements that have come from the other
side are not true it is not true that
the European
leaders removed governments that they
didn't like it was the peoples of the
countries concerned who removed those
governments who failed them it is not
true that the problems of Cyprus today a
cause by anything to do with the
European Union the European Union has
tried to assist and let me also tell you
that sometimes a picture is presented of
us constantly being overruled by our
partners being outvoted but when I was
responsible for financial services in
Europe and for the development of the
common market with its rules in relation
to banking insurance and securities we
were never overruled
not once and I have to tell you my
German counterpart he was outvoted so
long as we are able to persuade our
partners and we are able to persuade
them that it is in our interests and in
theirs to follow a liberal open policy
we are infinitely stronger doing so as
part of the European Union than doing so
as an individual country are on our own
and that is the key point that we have
to make we are not constantly being
overruled
we are often and again and again winning
the argument and getting Europe to
pursue policies on our behalf which we
could not have the strength to pursue
effectively are on our own that's the
economic case for European Union and I
don't accept a tool for a single moment
the talk that is made of 27
Commissioners making laws that's not how
the very European Union works it's a
limit howler to say that the Commission
has the right to put forward rules that
they never become law unless the Member
States by overwhelming majority and some
cases by unanimity actually support them
so what I would say to you
is that if we left the European Union we
would be economically weaker we would be
politically weaker we would be more
isolated we would be less influential so
how long after the divorce would we
continue to be happier about three
months in my estimate
Leon Brittan thank you very much indeed
so you've heard the remarks for the
motion and against the motion the floor
is now yours we want to hear what you
think for or against but before we hear
from you I want to tell you how you were
thinking when you came into this hall
27% a quarter of you didn't yet know
hadn't made up your minds but for the
motion was 30 percent 43 percent was
against the motion
so that's the way you were thinking as
you arrived we will be holding another
ballot before you leave and I'll be
announcing that at the end there's much
to play for one quarter of you have not
made up your minds let's hear now from
the audience and our panelists will get
involved as well please for or against
and be brief undecided it seems to me
that the main issue seems to be between
EU membership and efter membership and I
wonder if the panelists could tell us a
bit more about that Swiss and Norwegian
option that dan Hanlon was talking about
the common complaint is that you have to
sign up the rules but you don't have any
say in making them is that a good
argument for us to stay in the EU or not
not Britain there's been a very good
independent study by a distinguished
British writer David Beckham but the
Swiss and the Norwegians and the lessons
for the UK and the conclusion is that
would Britain be better off outside the
EU with Norwegian and Swiss style
association agreements and to summarize
it and I think fairness so the answer is
no because these association agreements
increasingly frustrate many Norwegians
and Swiss and the EU itself and so they
don't like the fact that they have no
say in the making of the rules but they
in practice have to implement the rules
and you're getting hot under the collar
there what are the latest polls in
Norway in Switzerland then my lord I'm
Fred I couldn't well I could let allow
me to enlighten you then because they're
doing so badly out of it as you just
said that 80% of Norwegians and 79% of
Swiss with all of these anomalies and
imperfections prefer their
current status to full membership and
can you blame them look at their GDP
look at their unemployment you know the
not the the pro-eu campaign in Norway
has folded shop Norbertine the fact is a
doorway is a democracy and if in fact
the consequences of the situation which
they were in now I was intolerable of
course they could change it the reality
though is that they do have to apply
rules which they have no say it creates
yes now about 1 million jobs I don't
have to tell us to answer you because
the essence of democracy is that you
listen to other people as well as talk
yourself and and and the fact the matter
is that Norway does not want to change
our the important difference is this
that whereas Norway with all due respect
to them is a small country and may be
content to apply rules which they have
no say in I don't believe in this
country we would want to do that
the Norwegians have just vetoed the
Postal Service's directive because they
actually want to keep their post office
is open in their rural communities the
Norwegians have redefined their
relationship with the European Union
they will put up with some of the rules
but they won't put up with all of the
rules but this idea that somehow life is
worse in Norway and Switzerland
I heard commissioner pascal lamy the
Trade Commissioner say but if Britain
was to reject the Lisbon Treaty we would
be relegated to a country the status of
Switzerland I thought what I don't know
Katinka to the sound too bad to me
just last week I had a bunch of
Norwegian parliamentarians in the office
the fact is since they joined the EEA
the European Economic Area they have
taken over 8,000 pieces of single market
legislation the postal directive is the
first time they have employed their veto
right at the back please
Hill farmer from Dartmoor how do you
account for the French agricultural
policy V the English are you for or
against most certainly against
next question in front of you please
Margaret Brett from Oxfordshire I'm for
the motion I would just like to know how
many of the audience know who their
European MEP is well let's let's try
that how many of you do I fear I can't
see everyone up there but I have a new
10 fingers and I suspect it's a stretch
even to get that far okay your point
made with there's no question to the
panel over there please
I was against I'm been slightly swayed
by the lack of arguments from my old
friend Leon Brittan who forty years ago
we campaigned in North Kensington on
behalf of the referendum to stay in
Europe and then it was sold as a trade
association please give us some of the
arguments why it has to be so political
trade association I was always in favor
of it's a niggly pigley social policies
is that I don't like niggly pigley
social lien Leon Brittan niggly pigley
social policies can I just say to you
Steven that I have a quotation which I
used to carry around it's a bit rusty
now from Harold Macmillan and Harold
Mellon said in 1962 that any idea that
the european common market as it then
was was only a matter of trade was
mistaken it was very much more than that
i he saw that as long ago as then and he
was right Nigel Farage I'm sorry I mean
I was too young to vote in that
referendum in 75 but I remember it and I
remember my parents both voting yes and
I remember all the political parties and
all the newspapers and the television
all making it clear as the gentleman
there said this was about trade it
wasn't about politics and now we hear
people like you saying that right from
the start we knew it was political
frankly the British people were lied to
by the pitiful class in this country
and it's time we had our say again
on the straight up on the gallery Emma's
at clip for the motion I wonder whether
we should not be worried by something
not mentioned yet by any of our speakers
which is ever closer political union and
integration to which the EU is being
driven by the extent of indebtedness
thank you maybe could I ask the panel
about the one salvation for this whole
debate is that Britain managed rightly
or wrongly at the time to avoid becoming
a member of the common currency
Katinka bearish that critical question
about ever closer political Union the
phrase ever closer political Union has
been taken out of the EU treaty you're
fighting windmills it's not even there
anymore
what is happening on the continent is
that the countries are driven by the
euro crisis to deeper integration nobody
suggests that Britain should be part of
this we are busy enough thank you very
much it is a great ideas is actually at
the moment fortuitous that Britain
didn't join the euro and everybody on
the continent knows that this is going
to stay though let the Europeans get on
with saving their single currency with
doing what they have to do but this does
not mean that Britain has to leave the
European Union but they can't save their
single currency it's a doomed project
the north and south of Europe cannot fit
together and survive together inside the
same economic and monetary union had it
been Germany and a few of the northern
countries it might have worked but this
is doomed
so don't say that it doesn't affect us
it does affect us but actually ever
closer Union as we now know it was there
from the very beginning but they're
using the crisis in the euro it's called
the beneficial crisis in Brussels it's a
phenomenon amongst the bureaucrats the
lian Britons of this world that if there
is a crisis you use it to integrate
Europe yet more deeply and they're doing
it to a level that I think is fanatical
and dangerous because they're not asking
the people in the member states with
they want to give up the ability to set
their own budgets and govern their own
countries and that's why you're seeing
violence and political extremism on the
streets of those Mediterranean countries
if you take away from people their
ability to determine their own futures
they will react violently against it
this is now a very dangerous bad
political project yeah a little bit of
accuracy might help I've I've always
been a politician and the appointments
as a commissioner as a political
appointment and not a bureaucratic one
thank you we weren't elected but I think
that that point can't happy allowed to
go completely unchallenged it is
extraordinary that we concentrate
executive and legislative power with 27
commissioners who are invulnerable to
public opinion and immune to the ballot
box so a year ago in Italy and in Greece
we saw Brussels backed cooze we're
elected prime ministers were toppled and
replaced by Eurocrats who'd never sought
office in their life who headed what
were called national governments but
were in fact government's put together
for the sole purpose of imposing an
agenda which would have been rejected
once by their people in a general
election there was not one elected
politician in Mario Monti s cabinet not
one he appointed himself finance
minister as well as Prime Minister it
was a government of 10 meaning to the
phrase was it go full-on threats one
thing one thing dead-dead YouTube and
the brussels borough crats have
certainly in common is that you equate
the European Union with Brussels my
European Union has 27 member states
maybe you should get out well there's a
lot in Brussels that if the EU were a
country applying to join itself it would
be disqualified for not being a
democracy and can you argue with that
right when you have 27 people making not
only executive or legislative
deliberately invulnerable to public
opinion I'm really glad to hear from you
because don't restrain your emotions in
this debate don't go over the top but
don't restrain your emotions let's get
some more thoughts right at the back
please my name is Christina and I'm
against the motion
my question is to Daniel a large part of
your speech focused on the fact that if
we remain within the European Union we
will be prevented from signing
free-trade agreements
you didn't point out that the EU itself
has a whole raft of free-trade
agreements which if we leave the EU we
will have to renegotiate on an
individual basis which will take a
gargantuan amount of time Germany is a
member of the European Union it manages
to trade with the rest of the world
perfectly well as well as taking
advantage of what the EU can offer why
doesn't the UK simply just do the same
thank you I'm Jonah and I'm for the
motion I was going to ask
assuming we actually left the European
Union two years after with the banking
industry within the UK which is very
important was would it be larger or
smaller and if it was smaller where
would that trade go to thank you there's
a lady over there my name is Rosa
Crockett I'm proud to be British and
within Europe and I am in I'm against
the motion
could I just take the emphasis away two
things do bother me about staying in
Europe one is that we have to keep
moving to tread Strasbourg every so
often which must be a huge drain on our
funds and secondly we haven't talked yet
about the free movement of people within
Europe who can claim our benefits that
we have over here I don't disagree with
free movement but our benefit systems
throughout Europe and up the same and I
don't agree with them and being open to
everybody each of you will pick up all
the things that grab you further back
there's a gentleman here as well please
there seems to be an implicit assumption
that the one thing at the center of all
this that is a value is the
in the common market from what I read it
seems to me that there is a negative
cost to us being in the common market
because of the jury-rigging and various
regulations and so on could you comment
please thank you up there please Andrew
Fletcher I'm tending in favor of the
motion at the moment and I have a
question for the panel is it correct or
is it a myth that the EU does not have
audited accounts and if it is correct is
that a matter for concern thank you the
lady here Thank You Linda topping I
voted to go into Europe but I would very
much vote to come out of Europe economic
migration is out of control it is
breaking our hospitals at housing and
our welfare what's happening today is
nothing as to what will happen in five
or ten years time and we will see open
riots on this street because our
youngsters will not be able to find work
I will definitely vote to come out pick
up these points in a moment please up
put on the gallery there my question is
how can you have a truly common market
without a common currency or at least
pegged exchange rates because otherwise
countries can just manipulate their
exchange rate that their currency in
order to give them an unfair advantage
it so that wouldn't be a common market
that's my question
right a one more over there please Peter
Florence there are 27 member states does
the EU state a limit on that number of
states we have Turkey in Waiting which
would give us neighbors of Syria Iraq
and Iran right as we wait for the
answers I want you to prepare to vote
let me now ask you to pick up on some of
those critical questions we've heard
from the audience getting a bearish
distrust work Parliament absolutely
nonsense let's stop it the EU budget
doesn't get signed off also scandalous
but the reason for that is not
necessarily what they do in Brussels
most of the EU money gets spent in the
Member States we would have to be
squeaky clean in 27 countries and we
have never met
to do that that is bad that needs to
improve I share your concerns about
people coming in here claiming benefits
there's one thing that puzzles me
there's more people in this country in
work at the moment than ever before
where does this fear come from if you
look at the East Europeans on benefits
the share is one-third that it is of the
British people and studies have shown
that the East Europeans in every year
since 2004 have been net contributors to
the Treasury because they paid more
taxes than they take out of the writings
instead those studies you can look at
all sorts of different ways let me just
throw a figure back at you would you
agree with her no I don't at all I don't
at all when you have more people in the
country when you have more people in the
country the size of the economy is
bigger but that does not mean that the
net productivity per capita is bigger so
I think you know we can play games with
figures I tell you what is horrifying
though there are 68,000 Romanians living
in Britain that we know of in the
metropolitan police area alone in the
last five years there have been 27
thousand arrests of Romanians now
immigration over decades has brought
many good hard-working people into
Britain but being members of the
European Union we haven't even got the
right to chuck out people who come here
with criminal intent and that is
something that by this time next year
will be the hottest issue in British
politics Lord Britain there are so we've
heard in this debate so many emotive
feelings as much as anything about
Europe how do you clarify that we've had
a continued bearish sayings not true
there's Closer political union so how do
you change the perception if this is so
critical for Britain I don't think there
is a easy way out of that I think quite
honestly that we have not been well
served by our written media and I
underline the written media which for a
long time have had a great influence and
have been owned by people who are
passionately opposed to the European
Union and therefore naturally enough
present a picture which is not exactly a
balanced one can I just say an answer to
well
the questions that was raised limit to
the number of states there's no
artificial limit to the number of member
states but no country can become a
member of the European Union except by
the unanimous vote of the existing
members so we have a veto of new members
but there's not a numerical limit to
their number just a word on the Eastern
Europeans let's not forget the Polish
example is a very good one the poles
came here in huge numbers half of them
have gone back they've gone back to
Poland and they've gone back to Poland
because things have got better in Poland
and there's no country which are on a
cross-party basis was keener on the
admission of the euro Eastern European
countries than this country we felt we
had a moral obligation to them we felt
that it was right that they having
served and suffered under communism for
so long should be given the opportunity
to join the European Union and the
European nation states collectively and
I personally think that we were right to
take that view note Brittany
Lord Britain and katika Paris you heard
from the lady at the front though a very
emotive view about the fear of the
impact of migration and European
movement freedom and mobility which is
at the heart of the Union the fears here
in this room the economy we almost
admire is the United States which is an
economy which is built on openness and
flexibility this is also what has made
this country great
I am fully understand the fears of the
access to welfare next year the
Bulgarians and the Romanians will have a
choice of 26 other countries to go to
because all the countries are opening up
there are at this present point in time
three times as many Bulgarians and
Romanians in Germany as there are in
Britain where do you think they're going
to go there are these concerns people
are working together on them this is not
a reason to leave the European Union
shut your doors Daniel Hannan
what we heard from Lord Britain a moment
ago has been the justification of every
anti-democratic system in modern times
people are led astray false
consciousness these wicked anti European
press barons you're all too stupid to
make your minds up and therefore we
can't trust the people let me deal with
three of the points of the many that
came the cost of all went as a
correction in mind you disagree with me
but I do object you mr. presenting me
because I didn't actually say which was
just a debate because it's a
prescription it's being it's a
caricature I didn't say that I was asked
a question why is opinion not aware of
the positive sides of the European Union
and I said that one of the reasons why
was because of the ownership of a very
substantial portion of the media by
people who are very anti European very
good fairies except direction well
that's that's another way of saying the
same thing you're blaming them blaming
the message of people are not able to to
understand the full facts because
they're being misled by the media fine
we put it how you how you like let me
say let me if I may deal with some of
the points that came up on the cost of
the euro we can see how high
that cost is we can see it measured
across the Mediterranean in unemployment
deflation poverty and emigration we can
see it in record levels of joblessness
and we can see it in Cyprus in savers
additionally being gouged in order to
prop up the monetary union which has now
been elevated as an end in itself more
important than the welfare of the people
who have to use the euro in one sentence
to answer the lady about Strasbourg
Strasbourg is a symbol of how pointless
it is to delude ourselves that we can
fundamentally transform the European
Union into something it's not
for 40 years British ministers have
solemnly stood up and promised to end
the monthly peregrination between the
two seats just as they've solemnly
promised to reform the Common
Agricultural Policy just as they've
promised to be more generous to
third-world producers in developing
countries we have got to the point where
we can say we make we gave it our best
shot we tried to change the nature
fundamentally we failed what is in our
gift is how much longer are we going to
be part of it
I remind you that the motion is Britain
and the EU would be happier if they got
divorced I'll remind you how you voted
when you came in to the beginning of
this debate 27% of you didn't know what
you felt 30% of you supported this
motion 43% were against well 22% of you
have taken a very clear view only 5% of
you now are undecided there has been a
dramatic swing against 47% for the
motion
48% the motion is carried
thank you
you will make your own judgment as to
what has happened here in Cadogan Hall
but there's been a dramatic swing and
certainly those proposing the motion
have succeeded in persuading you and
those against the motion were able to
convince those of you who were still
against the motion to stay against the
motion but not really persuade anyone to
join them so thank you very much indeed
for a very spirited debate here our
thanks to the speakers our thanks to you
here in Cadogan Hall in London it's been
a fascinating debate
my thanks to intelligence squared as
well for making it possible it's goodbye
from me Nik gowing from all of us thank
you bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you